اسئله كبرى تملا الفضاء السياسيه في
السودان هذه الايام عما يدور وراء
التفاهمات السياسيه بين العسكريين
والمدنيين والتي ترعاها الرباعيه تمهيدا
لبدايه لقاءات مباشره وغير مباشره اعلنت
الاليه الثلاثيه عزمها على انقاذها قريبا
في المكون العسكري جاء على لسان البرهان
في حديثه للقوات الخاصه بقاعده المرخيات
العمليه ابرز الرسائل القبول بوثيقه
المحامين كاس اساس للحلق والتطلع لحكومه
كفاءات والقطع بان ليست هناك تسويه ثنائيه
هكذا قال البرهان
شو يا ثنيه نحنا صحيح في واحده في ورقه
قدمت نحنا عملنا عليها حق الجيش البتاع
فضل الجيش كرمته تحفظ جيش وحدته تحفظ لي
الجيش استغلاليته
رسائل البرهان تلقتها القوه السياسيه
الفاعله المجلس المركزي للحريه والتغيير
رحب بتصريحات البرهان ومضى فيما ذهب اليه
رئيس مجلس السياده بعدم وجود تسويه وانما
عمليه سياسيه تهدفوا لانهاء الوضع القائم
ليس هنالك عمليه سياسيه او اجراءات لانهاء
وضع قائم واقامه سلطه مدنيه تلبي تطلعات
الشعب السوداني هذه السلطه المدنيه يجب ان
تدعمها قائد الانتقال
هو الحريه والتغيير الكتله الديمقراطيه
بدورها ترفض التسويه الثنائيه كما ترفض
الاحتكاما الى وثيقه المحامين فاساس للحل
لو في اي حوار في اي وفاق يتم يتم مع كل
القوى السياسيه الموجوده في الدوله
السوداني سوداني وانا سوداني ما عنده الحق
انه يفرض عليه ورقه يجب نجلس كلنا مع بعض
ونضع الاوراق دي ونتناغش في كيف انه ممكن
نقدر نودي الدوله
يتسق مع بيان الاليه الثلاثيه الاخيره وان
الحل يجب ان يشمل الجميع الرسائل هنا
واضحه جدا انه التسويه التسويه شامله وليس
التسويه ثنائيه دستور المحامين هو موقف
ايجابي لكن في حدود توضيحات هذه
يعني بتعديلاته الحاجه الثالثه
عبر الانتخابات
تقارب في الرؤى السياسيه مع بعض المكونات
وتباعد من البعض هكذا تمضي ديناميكيه
لعمليه السياسيه في السودان والتي لم تتضح
رؤيتها حتى الان نظرا للتباعد في المواقف
واسس الحلق محمد عثمان العربيه الخرطوم